if the brutality of the belarusian
police is not putting off the protesters
it is also not letting up
sundays like this are becoming the norm
peaceful protesters linking arms to
defend themselves against
military-clad law enforcement batons in
hand
people picked off one by one and dragged
into police fans
at least 400 arrests and that was in
minsk alone
in the drosd district of the capital
riot police chased people down the back
streets
you can hear a shot being fired
just a warning the interior ministry
says people scrambling over walls
desperate to get away from the swarms of
riot police on their tail
as usual the main event was peaceful and
festive
over a hundred thousand in minsk as
there have been every sunday
and thousands more in other belarusian
cities
but they know their president is in this
for the long haul
i don't think the authorities will give
up soon they do not want to
even today there were detentions of
peaceful people
who were just walking in the city like
we are now
unfortunately the dictatorship cannot be
toppled fast
i think we need to go on because all the
protests will end if we stop coming and
doing anything
our hope is to continue doing it
publicly so that more and more people
all over the world react to our
situation
president lukashenko has tried to pass
these protests off as the result
of western meddling he will meet the
russian president in sochi on monday
as the two countries start annual joint
military drills on belarussian territory
lukashenko's message to vladimir putin
via an interview on russian state tv
that if his regime falls then russia
will be next
dana magnay sky news moscow